[Music]
coaches and league of legends are an
unseen force
claritin a predominant younger self
hellooo you ain't gonna get up to that
control your there I buy again over $10
to double go compiler that comes with
always alone they're the glue that keeps
the world's greatest teams together and
the minds behind the game's biggest
moments SKT will be your first ever
two-time world champion
undisputed best even
to the average viewer their work is
mostly invisible fighting right there
but behind every brilliant draft every
meta innovation there's a group of
resolute coaches and analysts that push
the scene forward Parramatta magnifier
on Uganda definitely a leader under the
poppy each one innovators strategists
leaders they are the game's unsung
heroes and among the Great's there's one
coach who stands apart his teaching arts
how to make the arts in legal lessons
not teaching legal reasons that's what I
felt
managers join SKT it was completely
different to annotate the league of
legends just playing the game like in
summoners rift there's coma arts and
then he's trying with play and I just
following his you know ordering this is
the story of one of the greatest coaches
in league of legends is history this is
the story of coma
[Music]
Kim coma Jung Hyun's career didn't begin
as a league of Legends coach originally
he was a Starcraft 2 player co-op laid
under the hand a little boy for team old
generations but after failing to qualify
for gsl code a he decided to jump ship
to a new up-and-coming game that was
taking Korea by storm
[Music]
he jungled for startale in the earliest
days of Korean League but his brief pro
career petered out after startale placed
9th to 16th in the spring 2012 champions
tournament
kkoma left the team in April but by late
2012 his career took a fateful turn and
the Starcraft 2 player turned jungler
became a coach he joined a growing SKT
organization one that in February would
add their fledgling t1 to roster a new
team built around soloqueue superstars
t12 was packed with talent from
mechanical prodigies like impact and
piglet to the stable and powerful thingy
and poohmandu but of course the team's
heart was it's mid laner a 16 year old
phenom named faker salute all men and
hoministe' no Lee tae Joon will merge to
suffer then we elemental matinee of
finical to Bluebird one day they told me
to model in different from the patina
mahogany taking guarantee I get well but
what faker then lacked in maturity he
more than made up for in raw unstoppable
talent his mechanics are just so good to
keep up even under turn yeah I mean I
was curious to see how well having been
doing this thing because he's been
typically a relative
Bishop Baker just executes ambition to
that midlane in spring 2013 t12 placed
third after dropping to the eventual
champions MVP ozone and the semi-finals
even in that first tournament t12
cemented themselves as SK T's strongest
roster but it wasn't until the summer
split that coma and his team hit their
stride and look at ryu
he knows this / champion summer is over
SK Telecom coming back after being two
down there goes the Nexus GG incredible
reverse all-kill coming out of SK
Telecom there's coma the coach in the
food ahead of the season three World
Championships in Los Angeles SKT had
cemented themselves as Korea's greatest
hope they made world's 2013 their
playground is gonna slow down the
entrance but it's not gonna be a huge
amount impact is keeping on three
members of TSM the first victim will be
expecially he got the crescendo down but
it's not gonna be enough to save them as
now iris will be the second victim of
the fight
that's a double kill for a piglet is
enough flashes over the wall triple kill
as he turns at the wild turtle this is
going to be the Quadra does pick up the
Quadra kill no kill secured yet okay
looking for the hook not gonna connect
fakers still alive no not need to
trouble he's got the short waster then
there is the short wave coming there of
a faker so very low
together kill just gonna kill baekje
will bring it back though they've
answered into the fight Royals helpers
are just getting to farlis who's the
other outside true do what he can but
it's not going to be enough who's he's
chased into the base and hesitated he
wakes up for the eighth the cuadrado and
it quickly became evident that no one
could match s Katie's raw power it does
not look good for royal this does
letting it push enter catches all of
them it's a double for in fight they get
on the mountain SK Telecom I just roll
is through the Nexus turrets are
potentially going to go down this could
be a 20 minute game for us Angelica they
will be the season 3 1 champions here at
the Staples Center
SKT returned home to Korea triumphant
and unstoppable in champions winter SKT
played the only perfect season in Korean
league history taking their second
domestic title without dropping a single
game SKT were untouchable though coma
was the coach of the most successful
League of Legends team in the world he
managed to fly somewhat under the radar
in the earlier days of competitive
league coaching was an underappreciated
and poorly understood skill in fact back
in 2012
there were hardly any coaches to speak
of especially in the West in the early
stages of se season two
they're basically weren't any coaches
available everything was very player
driven there was nobody to really
resolve conflict because everybody was
involved in every single conflict there
was no neutral party to kind of oversee
the team and that led to a very chaotic
scene with a lot of breakups and a few
good teams kkoma was part of the first
wave of coaches in the competitive scene
but unlike the west Korea had something
of a blueprint in place when it came to
coaching and eSports team many of komuz
peers were pro players who had very
little coaching experience and in the
West the idea that players should
respect their coaches had yet to fully
take root
but koma implemented a strict system
working closely with his players and
along with his head coach was
responsible for laying some of the
groundwork that korean league coaching
infrastructure would grow on in 2014 a
new power was rising in korea samsung
ozone who were later known as samsung
white and their sister team blue were a
dominant force to champions spring and
summer in the spring SKT were toppled by
Samsung ozone in the quarterfinals
closed it out after a season with zero
losses for SK Telecom k including a 3o
of Samsung ozone in the finals ozone
will come back in the round of eight a
champion spray
and claim a 3-1 victory GG and the same
thing happened in the summer the damage
is just way too high and yes KCK doing
everything they can at this point but it
doesn't even make a difference the
damage on the em-pod on zip and impact
chasing a turret backs off but there
goes a nexus GG and samsung white on to
the semi-finals yet again taking down SK
Telecom K and the greatest heartbreak of
all came at the regional finals I think
it's gonna be an impact is all that
stands between najin shield and a trip
to the 2014 League of Legends World
Championships can he defend there's 30
seconds it's not gonna work
there's the first Nexus turn there's the
second and there goes the Nexus logic
shield it's going the world's the
defending world champions had gone home
to a perfect season only to miss the
next World Championship all together for
coma it was devastating if you followed
League of Legends then you've probably
heard analysts and broadcasters talk
about the incredible work ethic of most
Korean probes
well that work ethic extends beyond the
pros to their coaching staff as well
throughout his career
kkoma has cultivated a borderline
extreme work ethic don't fear the cruel
my buddy Hank Adamo Jim Tom tell Bob
from whooping across all those damn they
don't know I was fake goodbye Hyundai Oh
Agudelo Tioga proclaimed an agouti Monet
and been a minion and so as much as the
players were devastated by the loss
kkoma felt it too changes needed to be
made and heading into 2015 the korean
scene as a whole did just that coma
brought a new SKT roster into a new
Korea in 2015
piglet impact and poohmandu work out and
a new unified SKT with bang and wolf
alongside Mara in the top lane looks to
improve on 2014 and it was during that
first split that coma made one of the
more controversial decisions of his
coaching career wait wait what's this
what's this I spy in the SKT booth it's
that faker
it's easyhoon faker here's how we
operate we we pick our star player into
an unfavourable match and then we kick
about what he doesn't do well easyhoon
saw more playing time than faker
throughout the season and when it came
time to face their biggest domestic
rivals easyhoon played all three games
of SK T's final set against the GE
Tigers as often cuss me out buckle
on this lots of Kadampa day 17 in the
quiz I see Baker there to either give
the fans what you want go up or you save
Baker for MSI faker spent much of the
year grinding his way back and by the
time world's rolled around he was
usually in the starting seat but despite
their success in 2015 whether or not
benching faker was the right choice
telling the greatest player of all time
to sit was a tough choice
from the all anymore
who well tingling young wait since I
became the to hang again Jane Timoney
determining protector brings item value
by examining out yourself London day SKT
hit a snag at the inaugural midseason
Invitational but they returned home to
another domestic title in Korea and
heading into Worlds SKT looked like
Korea's best hope for a third
consecutive championship and four coma
this was an important tournament he
wasn't the leader of a brash young team
that could win on mechanical skill alone
he felt both the euphoria of a worlds
win and the bitter sting of missing the
tournament entirely and that loss had
made him stronger
no amoeba catenary receive a sentence of
KN cut sigue tango pasinetta been
dominant Antonio sabato yonago dr.
Torres McCoy Benitez evocative moon a
chimera and elm - - I know Hector no
team had ever won two World
Championships but this year was the year
to change that SKT hardly broke a sweat
on their way to the finals they went
undefeated in a group with the same EDG
that bested them at msi months earlier
they then swept AHQ and origin the last
team standing in their way was the same
one they'd overcome at the beginning of
the year and though the Koo Tigers put
up a valiant fight there is a moment of
the spectacle here we go home what a
head on the figure
is focused on to him he's forced to
class
it's the shock necessary a double coat
to the katsudon misspells very bad
thanks for SKT the bottom inhibitor is
already broken feeding super minions
into the base this is going to be modern
going down as well as he's too far from
home over the wall
bangs gonna go down now the fly in the
wall is left a few more hits
[Applause]
down it wasn't enough not even close
on the hunt goes in that's gonna be
hojin in a real sticky situation he goes
down a full three-man are ultimate
that's gonna be
away from his face SK Telecom looking to
take down the final Nexus turrets it
does not look good for Kuro and his team
Koo Tigers are falling SKT will be your
first ever two-time world champions
and they're spearheading the trend with
we get really inclusive with their
substitutions it's another thing that
puts SKT even further ahead of the
competition that they're all
with rotating at roster and actually
getting a lot of value out of music yeah
and I think that's where you end up
looking to other teams now and what they
end up taking away from this experience
at worlds from both their own
experiences but as well as from
witnessing the achievements of SKT
clearly this organization is doing
something right 2016 got off to a
predictable start SKT triumphed in the
spring split and rolled through msi but
they faltered in the summer split
playoffs putters yet actually was able
to make it out about the Guardians gonna
get Bob Sapp back from Duke is he's
trying to stick into the back arrow out
there they've gotta do it they take down
SK Telecom in the reverse sweep bringing
it back three kings in a row and they
are going to the finals on the 20th the
face against the rocks tiger heading
into Worlds some analysts thought of the
Tigers as the favourites to win it all
but for SK T's rabid fan base and the
organization itself anything short of a
third world championship would be
considered a failure players have
sometimes talked about the tremendous
pressure that comes with playing for SKT
and for coma the pressure was no
different he knew he had a team that
could win it all knew that his fans his
team expected victory
Yaiba Nando kangaroo kogo-sama portrait
avital to go on gentleman wasn't
[Music]
don't engage her on a bond investment
article on mobile because all day
Chattanooga kuduro spring rooster spring
i MMA style modern-day gurus obama
hanuman focusing on opening day that
what I see is something is hard
SKT you get it from the college coma had
built up a legacy as the world's most
decorated coach he was revered by his
peers and respected by his players he's
a better coach than me
that's a words from Ryu so that's a good
motivation for me cuz he's a pretty
honest person and he's nice so that's
like the nicest way he could put it it's
a really hard mark to look at and be and
look at it seems like they're wrong it's
hard to look at come and be like coma
you're doing it wrong right now but none
of that would matter if SKT failed at
Worlds after they made it out of groups
s Katie's first obstacle were Royal
never give up the Chinese squad looked
outmatched but all eyes were on their
semi-final opponents the Rox Tigers a
matchup that many fans had hoped to see
in the finals and from the very first
game it was clear this series would be
something special a pretty dangerous
spots done up in a baby
Maggie this could be it up there was a
trade went back and they will find me
Rox Tigers regular now it's 224 shoplift
I'm quaking Al and they're missing
plenty of CC but it's still two kills
picked up and running and it's nearly
finds a bird as well in Game two
the always creative Tigers came ready
with a counter to Zyra widely consider
the strongest support on the patch
support misfortune but when we're told
that's an insta luck miss horse and then
really weird I don't care about my last
point this is an insta lock misfortune
support MF it worked which means they
can play safe and play aggressive who
cares the two on to kill for the rock
Spotify beats IRA Pope you outraged it
with a pencil and then it worked again
also worth noting is sort of par for the
course is silk didn't quite a little
forth and here's the jump in a few more
attacks will do it and that's first
beautiful into a potential dragon
however 2008 is again there's the Sun
there's the pauli slow
and all the damage they could possibly
need gorilla gets the kill nothing wolf
could have done instead of getting out
of the lane entirely I c-can't II have
to change things up in this next one
because they tried round two of the mist
fortunately they lost again in the
timenado hundred okay - Matti Mogollon
uganda defending a leader hunter Bob th
one in Game four
kkoma chose to bring in bengi who'd been
sitting on the bench since he helped the
team to a game one victory part of the
reason for that was that blank had been
the starter for much of the year but it
was also that bengi had never played a
professional game on Nidalee one of the
patches most important junglers and one
of rock's peanuts signature picks but
unbeknownst to almost everyone
bengi was ready to player 30 volt by oh
[Music]
wow Oh
Nidalee was unbanned so bengi has to
play than Italy and it gives Ash's iris
straight over to Rox Tigers you gonna
help us a simple but say so no one said
anything so much you going okay by a
suitable Posada Tommy that okay Tom
supported them
oh yeah so it's all about Alberto no
think he gets funny here
there goes the girl the damage goes bang
so far so good for the first pick
Natalie getting away from it all that
mobs are gonna land either with a search
so low a gang he wants to die
and stays here break this one apart now
and now it could be dangerous bullet a
couple more shots
anyway bacon booty fire oh thanks again
anyway it's with bruised goodbye look
for the harass got hit and returned and
now the double bump forces of black
hooker this ton of a faker not gonna
matter
if you already have the OS and bangy
again and this could be the game when he
played right now Carl's got nothing left
to do sure he could pop the guardian
angel but what does it even matter
it's a-440 it's the 8th it's the game
'pinkie subs back and he sees SKT now
we're going to gain 5 and in game 5 SKT
were able to bring it home to qualify
for the world's finals though everyone
had expected Samsung to roll over they
put up a tough competition and took it
all the way to five games but in the end
samsung crumbled under the pressure and
SKT were champions once again I was able
to flash so he doesn't get caught by
Cubase down and it's a war of attrition
they're just waiting for the fight
deuk-gu flashes forward chops town to
kill crowd SK Telecom about to make that
three kills the curtain call is a
fitting end to the World Championship
and Samsung Galaxy are being dope under
their tower as
Telekom have overcome every challenge
they are the undisputed best team in the
world
no other organization has ever won
back-to-back World Championships until
comas SKT squad the dynasty he created
had broke ground in almost every way and
comas strict effective coaching was just
one aspect of that coma took some of the
most talented players that the game has
ever seen and elevated them he turned
stars into Superstars winners into
legends 2017 began with another domestic
victory and another MSI championship and
amid the success kkoma had settled into
his role as a fatherly figure on a new
team with young brash players like hooni
and peanut sometimes he had to temper
their play by on your body my
transantiago co-op is Linda I'm killing
it's going to be different in suis
chalie can this continuity by me others
oh no more deposit box bike will be
pressing it with Doha money will come
your cutting another Boulder there on
top it won't start now you wouldn't be
able sometimes he had to deal with
questionable life decisions like the
time peanut decided to turn on his
stream after a late night of drinking as
he always did kkoma made new pieces fit
into SK T's winning mold but eventually
everything comes to an end by the time
SKT mated to yet another a World
Championship the cracks were beginning
to show they were pushed to the brink by
Europe's misfits in the quarterfinals if
I had to
stay one reason that I lost game 23 is I
think the fall is on me
I think I should have been able to see
it through of how the game should have
went and I should have made some better
decisions and I think I should have been
a better coach and they took more body
blows against a surging orangy but now
the gal you turn to get the damage
across shields
ROG Bruzzi is coming for that final spot
and they are making a hard push here are
a state's goal game
back against 300
ha ha okay you mean you don't even I
didn't need to be with a value that I
the coma and SKT would eventually claw
their way back taking the series in a
grueling v game but by the time they
reached the finals it looked like there
was no gas left in the tank and Samsung
Galaxy outclassed them the moment they
plant maker and they take out the heart
of SK Telecom that might be the flash
are that signaled the end of the SKT
dynasty the upset is completed the Celts
go throw the
Katie
Galaxy there 2017
champion it was a brutal loss for the
game's most decorated team but for many
fans and analysts it seemed inevitable
that they would bounce back SKT might
have fallen down but they always managed
to climb back to the top well I think
what is happening right here is that SKT
is pissed SKT is gonna be frickin pissed
and I think coming into the next season
they're going to come in with the roster
is gonna be scarier than before and when
that day comes you know people will be
like holy moly look at this cutie roster
you know I think they've always been a
force to be reckoned with this is going
to just you know people have awoken the
dragon but it didn't happen that way
[Music]
20:18 was the darkest year in SK T's
storied history
they placed fourth in the spring
playoffs and after his team was
eliminated from the spring split coma
found himself on the longest albion
unexpected break of his career
Kiara Mesopotamia so we're you guys a
Tom Patterson are a Yamaka tiene todo el
aumento de dos tres las policías Travis
Nia yada
Munakata Michigan in talega region what
in the OOH hi c'mon c'mon c'mon Verona
co-op settle your body in the row then
they fell all the way to seventh in the
summer split by the time the regional
finals rolled around SKT missed out on
worlds entirely for only the second time
in the organization's history as the
coach kkoma has always shouldered the
blame for his team's failings and
throughout a year of disappointing
results he seemed to grow more withdrawn
as the year went on this year more than
any before he felt the pressure of being
on SK Telecom Otto tono omoide I'm a
hockey Gabbar America tameka's attempt
at a coup de baño teams rock canyon de
sumidero McCool putting a comfortable to
be $2 mr. Falzone even come to observe
one little window for another game
it's nice to know for years there's been
a running joke in the Korean seen about
comas marital status friends players and
fans have told the longtime coach he
should settle down and get married
especially since he's approaching his
mid-30s
nabela tequila all right yeah recruiting
name on the wedding march Hashanah
wife's Auriga playing the marriage a
blank stock he knows about Monday
so Gaekwad Rica and though it's mostly
in good fun a 20-18 OGN interview with
longtime friend and caster danke did
shine some light on the toll that year
took on him an [ __ ] Joe Hana Koecher
you know in the offseason coma switched
roles within SKT moving to head coach
though he would no longer be the coach
appearing on stage with his team the
promotion gave him the chance to build
the team he wanted for 2019 according to
reports from invent global they went
after Teddy early on securing the
much-lauded Jin air ATC when the dust
had settled on the offseason s katie's
roster boasted Khan chlid and Mota
in addition to fakers always shining
star it was a powerhouse roster one that
faker called
a team of aces and though many younger
teams put up impressive results in
spring 2019 SKT reclaimed their throne
they toppled Griffin in a one-sided
finals and earned another shot at the
international stage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
if the memo meant to bask in the Octagon
estate she'd have destroyed team Griffin
to register their spot and the midseason
Invitational and also sadly MSI was not
as Katie's tournament to win despite a
strong showing in groups SKT fell in the
bracket stage against Europe's g2 for a
team that many Korean hopefuls believed
could win it all MSI was a failure still
for koma the success in his first
domestic split as head coach meant the
world and for the fans that had stuck by
SKT through a shaky 2018 it meant
everything
[Applause]
oh that thought
[Applause]
[Music]
there's no other coach in League of
Legends who can inspire a crowd to chant
their name like that there's no other
coach who could tame who could help to
perfect the greatest player of all time
who could mold the greatest team ever
if pitching arts how to make the Arts in
League of Legends not teaching League of
Legends that's what I felt managers
during SKT it was completely different
when I when I think the League of
Legends playing the game like in summer
strip
there's Como arts and then he's drying
with clay and I was following his you
know order no coach is as decorated no
coach is as dedicated know Coach is coma
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]